over the next couple of days i'm going
to share three key insights that i've
taken having interviewed over 80
recruiting professionals and recruitment
entrepreneurs this year on the podcast
so the first one hopefully will come as
a surprise to you but for me it really
isn't a surprise the best recruiters and
the best recruitment entrepreneurs that
i've interviewed that i've met possess
way more humility than they do ego one
of the most popular questions that i've
had in my inbox this year has been from
recruitment owners reaching out to me
saying hey hisham do you know any great
non-execs do you know any great
consultants that i can speak to that can
really help me scale my recruitment
business i don't know the answers i'm
willing to get help and ask for help do
you know anyone that can help and that's
accompanied with top performers top
builders who end up in my inbox asking
if i know anyone that can help them with
a certain part of their recruitment
skill set and something they want to
improve on although the industry doesn't
have the best rep for people thinking
that everyone has egos in the
recruitment industry for me i think the
best recruiters the best recruiting
entrepreneurs really possess way more
humility than they do ego and that's the
first key insight that i've taken from
this year's conversations
[Music]